si yo me encontrara con este problema en
un examen de matemáticas seguro me
pondría muy nerviosa pues se ve bastante
intimidante pero en realidad no es tan
complicado es un problema clásico de un
sistema con dos lentes y sobre todo
antes de que nos perdamos en los
detalles aquí la idea general sobre cómo
vamos a trabajar en esto es como sigue
tenemos dos lentes el primer lente va a
crear una imagen de este objeto así que
crea una imagen de este objeto y ahora
el segundo lente va a crear una imagen
de esta imagen y básicamente vamos a
usar la fórmula del lente delgado pero
primero vamos a imaginar que este
segundo lente no existe primero vamos a
ver cuál es la imagen creada por este
primer lente y después imaginamos que el
primer lente no existe y trataremos la
imagen que fue creada por el primer
lente como si fuera el objeto del
segundo lente haremos otros cálculos y
veremos en donde este segundo lente nos
crea la otra imagen nos crea la imagen
de lo que este lente piensa que es el
objeto aunque es la imagen del otro
lente aunque en realidad es la imagen
del primer lente así que primero el
objeto se vuelve una imagen por el
primer lente y luego esa imagen es
transformada por el segundo lente en
otra imagen y esto es lo que verá
nuestro ojo así podremos responder a
esta pregunta qué imagen de tu ojo en
este caso nuestro ojo va a estar viendo
a través de estos dos lentes lo primero
que vamos a hacer es imaginar que el
segundo lente no existe para no
confundirnos y usamos la ecuación del
lente delgado 1 / efe
bueno aquí vamos esta distancia es de 12
centímetros pero serán positivos o
negativos si está a la izquierda quizá
lo vea como negativo
lo único que nos interesa es qué tipo de
lentes y este es un lente convexo lo
sabemos por la forma en que está
dibujado y si éste es un lente convexo
mi distancia focal va a ser de 12
positivo 12 centímetros positivo y esto
es igual la distancia del objeto
aquí tenemos este 24 es esta nuestra
distancia no todas las distancias se
miden desde el centro del lente hasta el
objeto que queremos ver así que tengo
que ir desde el centro del lente hasta
el objeto no hay que poner cualquier
número que nos den tenemos que poner
nuestra distancia que es de 24 + 12 es
36 por lo que aquí pongo uno entre 36 36
centímetros positivos o negativos en
este caso van a ser positivos tenemos
dos lentes pero en este primer caso
tenemos que estar del lado izquierdo
todo está bien pues está del lado
opuesto a dónde está mi ojo esto es 36
positivo y en un momento les voy a
mostrar en qué
acaso esto sería negativo + 1 entre la
distancia de la imagen lo etiquetamos
como de y vamos a despejar esto y nos
queda 1 entre 12 centímetros menos 1
entre 36 centímetros y es igual a 1
entre b y nos queda 1 entre 18
centímetros del lado izquierdo esto es
igual a 1 entre b por lo que le iba a
ser igual a 18 centímetros
18 centímetros positivos y esto qué
significa en dónde va a estar mi imagen
esa cantidad es positiva y esto
significa que va a estar del mismo lado
en que está nuestro ojo tomando como
referencia el lente por lo que tendré
una imagen que se forma de este lado del
lente y estos 18 centímetros se calculan
desde el centro del lente si lo dibujo
aquí va a estar más allá del punto focal
ya que nuestro otro punto focal está a
12 centímetros mi imagen va a estar más
o menos por aquí
estos son 18 centímetros y es aquí donde
se va a formar mi primera imagen
la imagen creada por este lente bueno
como ya lo habíamos dicho ahora nos toca
tomar en cuenta el segundo lente sabemos
que la imagen creada por el primer lente
está aquí y este segundo lente va a
pensar que este es el objeto va a crear
una imagen de esta imagen como si éste
fuera un objeto vamos a usar de nuevo la
fórmula del lente delgado pero vamos a
tomar estos 18 no como si fuera la
imagen sino como si fuera el objeto sin
embargo esto no va a ser nuestra veo
recuerden que todas las distancias se
miden a partir del centro del lente así
que para esta fórmula la distancia al
objeto va a ser esta distancia a partir
de aquí y hasta acá y esto no son 18
centímetros por eso es que tenemos esta
distancia entre los centros de ambos
lentes
la distancia entre los lentes es de 33
centímetros por lo que si la distancia
de este primer lente hacia esta imagen
es de 18 entonces la distancia que resta
o la diferencia va a ser igual a esta
distancia 33 menos 18 va a ser igual a
15 15 centímetros va a ser la distancia
en la que este lente va a pensar que
está nuestro objeto y ese nuestro objeto
entre comillas por lo que transformamos
este 18 positivo de aquí
la distancia del objeto que es de 15
positivo porque positivo pues porque
seguimos de este lado izquierdo del
lente el lado opuesto a nuestro ojo que
es donde se supone que está el objeto y
aquí es donde les mencioné que podríamos
tener una distancia al objeto negativa
si nuestro primer lente hubiera creado
una imagen del objeto hasta acá del lado
equivocado del lente en otras palabras
si este lente hubiera creado una imagen
que se encontrara más cercana a nuestro
ojo de lo que se encuentra el segundo
lente sería un desastre tendríamos una
distancia al objeto negativa no se
supone que nosotros tengamos al objeto
entre nuestro ojo y el lente y bueno
nosotros podríamos seguir haciendo los
cálculos como siempre estos siguen
funcionando vamos a obtener una imagen
pero si tenemos este caso la distancia a
nuestra imagen va a estar del lado
equivocado del lente si así fuera creada
la primera imagen tendríamos que tratar
esto como una vista
negativa pero esto no es lo que sucede
aquí nuestra imagen se encuentra del
lado correcto del lente
ahora vamos a imaginar que este primer
lente no existe tenemos nuestro objeto
aquí esto lo vamos a tratar como si
fuera nuestro objeto y todo está bien
tenemos aquí a nuestro ojo aquí en medio
al lente y de este lado tenemos a
nuestro objeto por lo que esta distancia
va a ser positiva + 15 pongamos datos en
nuestra fórmula vamos a ver el 1 sobre
el punto focal y para conocer al punto
focal tengo que fijarme en qué tipo de
lentes
este es un lente divergente y los lentes
divergentes siempre van a tener un punto
focal negativo así que en esta ecuación
la contribución del punto focal va a ser
de menos 10 menos 10 centímetros es la
distancia focal de este lente
y esto es igual a 1 entre la distancia
al objeto que ya conocemos sabemos que
no es un objeto pero este lente no lo
sabe así que lo trata como a un objeto
esto es uno entre 15 centímetros
positivo ya que esto está del lado
correcto de la lente + 1 entre la
distancia de la segunda imagen por lo
que aquí pongo de la imagen que será
generada por este sistema de dos lentes
hacemos los cálculos uno menos uno entre
menos diez centímetros menos uno entre
quince centímetros es igual a uno entre
de invertimos esto y nos queda que es
igual a menos seis centímetros
y es aquí donde estará nuestra segunda
imagen que significa que sea menos seis
centímetros sabemos que lo medimos desde
el centro del lente y el menos recuerden
que una distancia de la imagen negativa
significa que la imagen va a quedar del
lado del lente que está opuesto a dónde
está nuestro ojo dibujo una línea que
parta desde el centro del lente y esté a
6 centímetros hacia la izquierda más o
menos por acá y estos serán 6
centímetros ya que esta es la distancia
a la imagen lo que significa que nuestra
imagen final va a estar justo aquí
nuestro ojo va a ver la imagen de algo
justo en este lugar en dónde está
nuestra imagen
vamos a repasar lo que hicimos primero
excelente creó una imagen del objeto en
este punto de aquí este punto de los 15
centímetros y el segundo lente creó una
imagen de esa imagen la trató como si
fuera un objeto y creó una imagen en
este punto blanco
aquí es donde veremos la imagen pero no
sabremos cómo luce esta fórmula del
lente delgado solo nos va a decir en
dónde va a estar la imagen si queremos
saber qué tan grande será tendremos que
usar la fórmula de la magnificación
vamos a hacerlo de este lado tengo que
la magnificación o el aumento menos de
ahí entré veo y cuánto fue de y en este
caso vamos a hacerlo paso a paso para
este primer caso de y fue de 18 positivo
aquí pongo 18 positivo y no incluyó las
unidades porque se van a cancelar de o
no fue 24 fue 36
por lo que me queda menos 18 entre 36 es
un medio esto qué significa bueno pues
que este primer lente creó una imagen
que es la mitad de grande que mi objeto
y el signo negativo significa que va a
estar de cabeza voy a dibujar esta
imagen de color naranja porque es el
color que use para calcular la va a
estar invertida y va a tener la mitad
del tamaño que el objeto original el
objeto era de este tamaño mi imagen va a
estar invertida por lo que esta va a ser
mi imagen 1 esto es lo que voy a usar
para mi segundo objeto eso es lo que voy
a usar como mi segundo objeto así que
esta imagen 1 será mi objeto 2 que
aumentó o magnificación va a
proporcionar este segundo lente a esta
imagen la magnificación o el aumento es
igual a menos de y / d
así que esto es menos la distancia a mi
imagen
en este segundo lente fue de menos 6
esto que calculamos aquí no ponemos las
unidades porque se cancelan y la
distancia al objeto de mi segundo lente
fue de 15 centímetros la distancia del
centro del lente hasta el objeto entre
comillas que en este caso fue de 15
positivo que nos queda si tenemos menos
menos 6 entre 15 nos van a quedar dos
quintos positivos este es el segundo
aumento el aumento o magnificación del
primer mente fue de menos un medio y la
magnificación o aumento del segundo
lente es de dos quintos positivo
significa que la imagen aquí que voy a
dibujar en blanco porque en este color
puse sus cálculos tendré una imagen que
va a ser dos quintas partes del tamaño
de la primera imagen este es un aumento
o magnificación de esta imagen esto es
lo que hace este segundo lente ya no
estoy tomando en cuenta mi objeto
original sino lo que este segundo lente
considera como objeto así que tiene un
tamaño de dos quintas partes de esta
imagen
el positivo significa que va a estar
hacia arriba aunque realmente significa
que no está invertida y como la imagen
que tomó nuestro segundo lente estaba
invertida o de cabeza ese signo positivo
significa que vamos a mantener la
dirección que tenía el objeto original
no se invierte por lo que dejamos esto
de cabeza si esto hubiera estado derecho
lo hubiéramos dejado igual derecho pero
en este caso lo dejamos invertido y va a
tener dos quintas partes del tamaño dos
quintos es un poquito menos que un medio
por lo que vamos a dibujarlo más o menos
así y justo así es como va a estar mi
imagen esto es lo que yo voy a ver un
objeto muy chiquito y de cabeza y este
es un ejemplo de cómo podemos trabajar
con un problema que tenga un sistema de
lentes tratamos por separado a cada uno
de los lentes y usamos estas fórmulas
como corresponde lo último que vamos a
ver es que si tenemos aquí dos aumentos
o dos magnificaciones habrá manera de
conocer cuál fue la magnificación o
total derecho sí y es bastante sencillo
si queremos conocer el aumento total o
la magnificación total porque factor voy
a multiplicar la altura original del
objeto de manera que me dé esta imagen
final
tomamos el aumento del primer lente y lo
multiplicamos por el aumento del segundo
lente si tuviera más lentes los
multiplicaría a todos y esto me va a dar
el factor del aumento o magnificación
total con lo que puedo multiplicar la
altura del objeto original para obtener
la altura de la imagen final así como su
orientación aunque esto no nos da la
posición solamente nos da el aumento
total lo que puede ser bastante útil si
vamos a hacer un microscopio por ejemplo
pero no nos da la posición para conocer
la posición tendremos que usar las
fórmulas de lente delgada y es así como
resolvemos un problema de lentes
múltiples